loser was gonna show their best example
home
Oh boom-boom oh they made me know now I
can't concentrate after that Oh what
hello I'm Chad red well I am so thankful
that he for whatever reason is I
murdered me yet I'm so so grateful what
do you know about season two man I read
it on the train down here yeah yeah
that's what I was reading um it's great
it's really good um it's really Ryan you
know when Ryan Murphy when you read like
those scripts and you kind of see what
kind of just sits in his brain it's very
weird he's got he's just got a demented
playground in his head that kind of
spills out on the page so I will say I
have to get in shape because I'm I'm not
closed a lot in script great I was like
I was like Oh ours I alright so Brian
that's me in the shower a lot absolutely
it was like we've got to get some more
nude Glen Powell cheese yeah it's a
pressure so um
workouts will start tomorrow nobody
breaks up with Chad right well
workout start tomorrow I'll just
hornbills do like a crunch just like
warning shot there I'm ready ready to go
yeah I'm Sam an all day and then just
one cringe Ryan Ryan Ryan set C he is
big on like the the pressure to look
good on those shows is it'll higher than
in real life I got everybody wants I'm
like athletes you know you drink beer
and you play baseball holy you don't
have to look but on Ryan Murphy shows
you know you shred it yeah he makes he
makes being naked a little bit of
high-pressure job